e
e e
and welcome to Transportation
committee's I believe final meeting of
the banum um just to deal with our
interim study bills before we get
started uh representative Koker would
you like to lead us in the pledge of
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America to the Republic for
which it stand
one na God indivisible liy and justice
for
all all right just briefly what we're
doing today uh for those of you that may
not have gone through this process uh
for any number of reasons we decided to
interim study these bills uh when they
were brought before us at least one of
them was actually a retain bill from the
first here and when we decided what to
do with that in January we still didn't
know what to do so we interum studied
that one as well the only two motions
that we're looking at today are whether
or not to recommend future legislation
or not and so we I we'll go through them
one at a time um we'll open them up for
discussion but at the end of the day uh
those are the only two motions we're
we're we're looking for and it's in
hopes that it'll save time next year uh
when anybody's filing a bill whether or
not where the transportation committee
already stands so that being said
uh the first bill will take up thank you
representative St Clair um House Bill 55
relative to driver
education uh is there a
motion
actually I see representative
Koker thank you Mr chairman I would make
a motion to uh recommend for further
legislation I just think that uh the
direction we've been going is hold on
hold on so the motion is to recommend
future legislation can I have a second
second by representative Hill would you
care to speak to your motion I know
we're all a little bit Rusty here it
doesn't take long I'm not that smart um
anyways so um I think that uh it
integrating the parents into children's
uh driver's education is important I
think it's something that we should look
into um obviously we ran into some
issues this year with how to like how
big of a role and you know how basically
how to check that the parents are
actually doing what they need to do but
I think that um I think that further um
legislation and um some further talks
about how we can integrate parents into
driver's education and keep it um safe
for the DMV is something that we should
uh look into so that's that's what I
believe thank you sir anybody else from
the committee
representative pondon thank you Mr chair
um I can support the further legislation
but I want to bring out another concern
that I have is just assuming that the
parents are good drivers and know the
laws of the road I think if you if we go
out and we test say a 100 drivers that
have been on a road for 10
years I would be willing to bet that 80%
of them don't know the basic like
parking 25 ft to corner or 15 ft from
hydrant all those basic things that a
new driver really really needs to know
so I would support further legislation
but just ahead of time I want to see
something of more of an onus on the
parent and also uh
documentation that would be provided to
uh the DMV maybe a certified document
saying stating that the parent did in
fact drive with the student the 18y old
so many hours just something
U holding them accountable but I would
support it but I think we need
definitely need more time and study on
this thank you Mr chair thank you
anybody else representative
SES thank you Mr chairman um I'm
somewhat in agreement with my colleague
at uh representative
panden um the way I would look at at it
is um
when on the current system we have
professionals who are teaching people
how to
drive and that's an important component
of their their abilities to drive well
and be safe uh and that's something
every parent and every citizen I hope is
always trying to keep people safe um the
problem that I see in having just the
parents
as part of the system uh with a track
that allows them to do that is that they
may not be in fact professionals and
so maybe as if if this bill is
recommended for future consideration
that one of the cons important
considerations should be that parents
have what I would might uh finally call
continuing education to make sure that
they're up to dat with the with the
types of vehicles that are now being
sold with the rules of the road that are
now under as we all know under a state
of conflict
U uh change all the time and so you know
that that is my concern um I I think the
bill as written um I can't support the
bill as it's written but there we
are representative Horan aren't you a
subtit
okay representative
Hill thank you Mr chair so
um I know uh what um what George is
talking about is true that we do want
safe roads but we are talking only about
ages 16 to 18 because at 18 um all bets
are off there's no requirement for
driver red so it is um it is really
talking about those two years and if um
if we were truly interested in the
safety of the roads we would be
requiring the driver red regardless of
the age so um I'm not really sure uh
well um there's another bill George um
you know but uh but for right now as it
stands um I I will uh agree with
representative Coker and um and follow
the recommendation for future
legislation and future
discussion representative Morgan
sure I'm just sub here I'm just a guest
just a very quick word smithing in the
event that someone uh someone around the
table wants to bring the bill back uh
you know in the next filing period the
uh wording they use the pH father mother
or Guardian twice or and then parent or
Guardian I think twice so it should be
uh first of all I think parent or
Guardian is a more inclusive phrase it's
probably better but in any event you
probably don't want to use two two
different phrases when you ask oh L to
write up a new version of this and
probably you know parents better that's
just not really a substan of comment
it's just a stylistic thing so yeah so
that anybody else no shut up
thank represent I saw representative
sellers
first thank you Mr chair so my only
thought and coming from a different
angle on this
is the less fortunate that don't have
the money to pay for driver's ed in
which this case they'll at least have
another option to be able to get their
license before they're 18 so that's why
I'm looking at this as
recommended represent represent rbo
thank you uh the one thing that held me
back class or one of the things that
held me back when we discussed this
earlier was the other another
responsible adult uh language included
in addition to parents and Guardians so
just mentioning that to the extent this
does get brought forward next time um I
feel like that's pretty Broad and we
talked a little bit about it could just
be 18-year-old friend and whether we
would feel comfortable with that as
somebody who could take on this
responsibility um I would like to see
that perhaps not included in the future
or at least talking about that going
forward representative St Clair thank
you um I'd be I would Echo all these
concerns except there's a test that's
administered by the state and if we
don't think the test is strong enough to
catch anybody that doesn't know all the
rules and what they need to know then
maybe it's a test we should be looking
at thank
you okay I we're we're on the on the the
course of rewriting the bill here but
um anybody
else I'll chime in I think this is a
horrible idea I always have this is the
second ter we've actually seen this bill
uh we are talking about driver Zed for
our kids 16 and 17 years old and I think
the system we have works the only reason
I supported interim study on this versus
an
itl uh was that I also do recognize that
we do need to do something about the
affordability and availability of driver
at it never used to be a problem when
the schools offered it uh why they don't
now is been brought up in discussion I
haven't got an answer uh but it makes no
sense to me if they still did offer it I
don't think we'd be having the
discussion on this bill at all right now
uh but because we did recognize the fact
that affordability and availability is
an issue I figured we'd wait and see
before we decided on this uh what the
Department of Motor Vehicles has
actually been working on to alleviate
those issues uh I don't know if you'd
like to chime in on some of his recent
progress I'm not throwing you into the
bus but um if you don't mind if what
have we been doing towards the goal of
uh availability and
affordability um that you've been
working on
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to um to highlight some of the work we
have been doing and um really enjoy
listening to the conversation about
driver's ed and um how we can move the
ball forward uh on that front uh one of
the things that we've been working on is
uh the affordability part so we
understand that um driver's education
today can be anywhere from $800 to
$1,000 that's a lot of money for young
people um so in working with the uh New
Hampshire Automobile Dealers Association
the New Hampshire Commission on human
rights and um the New Hampshire drivers
education Teachers Association uh we
have uh stood up a scholarship program
um nhada runs the program all the
finances go through nhada the
application lives on their website Dan
Bennett has been an amazing partner and
um we just rolled that out within the
last couple of months the applications
uh are coming in fast and Furious We
were fortunate to receive a
$225,000 donation from the um exitor New
Car Dealers Association and uh that was
about a month month and a half ago um
and that allows for about 50
scholarships but we're going to go
through that money pretty quickly um and
uh we've given out if I had to guess
we've probably given out at least um 18
or more than 20 scholarships so far so
if there was a way to continue funding
that we're doing it through private
donations uh we're trying to get the
word out but um certainly would love to
work with this body on some strategies
to um maybe have a pool of money that
either that scholarship could draw from
or another alternative where you had a
private public partnership in trying to
fund uh driver's ed for uh for young
people but the need is there um the
other thing we did was we worked with um
Employment Security and uh Deputy
Commissioner Rich labors commissioner
kadus I I'd like to thank him uh there's
a program there where you uh if you're a
qualifying employer can reduce the cost
um to go to school by 50% for certain
opportunities it fit with driver ed and
we just had Deputy Commissioner labers
at our monthly driver ed meeting uh last
month and he talked about the program
basically what that allows for if it's
$4,000 to go through the 12we program 12
to 15we program to get your driver's
education certificate from White
Mountain Community College uh you as an
employer hiring that instructor uh will
be in reimburse for 50% of that so that
opens up more opportunities for
instructors to come through which means
that that cuts down on the demand and we
have more uh opportunities
geographically around the state for
people to take drivers head um the way
it was explained uh Deputy lers has did
an awesome job uh basically what what
happens is you can do that once a year
apply for it up front it's like
Insurance you name the dollar amount and
the hiring you think you're going to do
and if you hire somebody you can use
that opportunity to offset the cost um
the other thing is I get a um uh a
monthly update on weight times around
the state um the state police uh who
currently uh well actually as of um
about a week and a half ago it's
switched now the DMV we have a full-time
position that oversees driver's ed
that's the first time in a long time the
DMV has overseen the program um that
gentleman uh Sam Bon started recently uh
he comes from the driver ed Community he
owned his own school um he's running the
program now but the state police have
been giving updates on the wait times
and there really aren't any for the most
part you're able to get right in that's
what I'm getting and I asked for uh a
sampling from each County around the
state on that so I guess I would step
away saying or take any questions wait
times are way down people are able to
access driver ed we have something in
place to try to offset the financial
need and we're trying to bring more
instructors in thanks to Employment
Security and the other response I got on
that was we're doing really well on
instructors people are coming in in
droves and uh schools are able to stand
up and operate their program so uh to
the chair's Point driver's education I
think in comparison to two years ago is
in a really good place um but there's
always room to support the industry and
for improvement so happy to take any
questions um just one quick one for me
has there been any further discussion
with the Department of Education on
possibly returning this to the schools
we did do that sir um we did that
probably over over a year ago um with um
Mr applebe um I've spoken with Diana
Fenton uh we we've I've asked those
questions because I've also had um
presentations on areas around the state
where that model still exists it it
exists in nsha um I drove by I think it
was nasua North High School and um and I
saw driver ed Vehicles out and back at
one point so I I inquired about that and
they the city of nashille runs a program
where the school is part of it so there
there are I think five different
districts around the state that still
still have that model that exists um
other states use that model my
understanding is when we had that model
in New Hampshire uh we had no issues uh
it ran very smoothly I in speaking with
Department of Ed I know that their
curriculum is very tight uh there isn't
a lot of flexibility or wiggle room
there to bring in other programs because
of some of the things that they have to
offer um that being said that driver
training fund um that is still on the
books that's that's covered by an RSA
that was where the funding came in to
allow for uh drivers had the cost to be
offset if we could ever get back to that
relationship I think that would be a
good thing because it
work thank you sir U representative Phil
got a question quickly yeah um thank you
for taking our questions um have you
ever talked with uh the um the insurance
department um specifically commissioner
Von Court about uh the idea of whether
if a school department does have that or
if there was widespread driver red
whether that would be um part of
lowering um Insurance costs for the
community um I didn't know if that would
be a selling point for a school
department for having it I think that's
a great idea I have not done that and um
and I will thank you I'll reach out
thank you
representative okay um again to this not
a public hearing I just asked him to
come up to give us an explanation of
progress that's being made so we can
decide on what to do with this bill okay
go ahead for those of us that do not
have not met could you just please state
your name for the record we were talking
to I'm sorry that's that's on me U sorry
sir uh John morasco director of the DMV
thank you and thank you for making sure
I didn't do my job this
morning um thank you very much director
thank you Mr chair appreciate it
okay anybody else from the committee uh
as I was saying u based on the
information that I and the progress I'm
seeing on the availability I'm uh I'm
not in favor of recommending
further uh legislation personally if I
nobody else has anything to say I will
call have the clerk call the role the
motion on the floor is to
recommend future legislation
whatever
you representative Gorski yes
representative Smith
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative
Dumis not
here representative foot
yes representative
C
no representative sellers yes
representative Coker yes Representative
syes
no representative St
Clair
yes representative
Fox
yes Representative
rbo
no representative Vu
no representative Horgan
no Representative flon
no Representative parel
no representative
Johnson not
here and chairman Walsh
no okay we have nine voting yes and
eight no
okay so the motion to recommend future
legislation is adopted 9 to8 thank you
in advance for your timely report
representative Coker we do have the
forms down here already uh so I'll uh
close the executive session on House
Bill 55 give us a minute to reset and
before again remiss um I'd like to thank
representative Shen for being our clerk
today representative Crawford could not
make it
and good afternoon Deputy speaker
Smith
e
e e
we get back to
it I'll open up the the executive
session on House Bill
646 eliminating the vehicle inspection
mandate for non-commercial vehicles uh
chair recognizes representative Gorski
for a motion thank you Mr chairman I my
motion is not to suggest future
legislation on this bill right the
motion is to not recommend future
legislation is there a second
representative G he'll second it can to
speak to your motion sir yes thank you
Mr chairman um
with this particular bill um I am a I
have no problem and we worked as a
committee to make some small adjustments
to the inspection program that could
help the citizens of New Hampshire I
have no problem with tweaks but this is
to
eliminate and you know I think that's a
little bridge too far for me I think um
the inspection program does serve its
purpose and to eliminate it um I think
is not a wise decision that's why on
against future legislation on of this
Bill thank you sir anybody else from the
committee yeah seeing none um I won't
belabor it I'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready the motion is
to not recommend future
legislation representative Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
foot
yes representative
C yes representative
sellers
no representative
Coker
Sykes yes Excuse me
yes representative St Clair
no representative Fox
yes representative Rambo
yes representative Vu
yes representative Horgan
yes representative plumon
yes representative parshall
yes and chairman Walsh
yes uh
three all right a recommendation of not
to rec commend uh is adopted 143 I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill
646 give us a minute to reset next step
is House Bill 650
all right I'll open up the executive
session on House Bill 650 FN relative to
prohibiting suspension of driver's
licenses due to non-payment of fines or
fees
uh chair recognizes representative C for
a
motion um I move that U the committee
not recommend this for future Rec uh
legislation uh motion is to not
recommend is there a second that's
seconded by representative Hill care to
speak to your motion sir uh yes um this
bill May provide for some unintended
consequences in terms of how we uh
collect findes and do
other uh issues with other in different
cases of the law and also the DMV has
explained that this is the very last
step that there are other things that
are done when they are notified that
there is a um a request to U suspend the
license thank you sir anybody else in
the committee representative
SE yeah so we've we have been trying as
a committee in the past to try and um
remove uh fines that uh are not tied
that that are imposed where there's no
connection to driving privileges and
while this bill as it's currently
written may have um some issues that
could be corrected I think that the the
process or the the hope to make sure
that we are
um not adding fines that would and the
you know to non-driver related causes
that cause a person to lose their
driving privileges and their ability to
work and their ability to
take uh kids to school and their ability
to get to the doctors Etc I think is um
a laudable goal and I look at this as
this is a goal that we should be
striving for as opposed to
necessarily um not by giving up on the
idea that was a that was a good one that
that should uh be followed through in my
opinion anybody else from the
committee wow we get all the time we
spent on 55 and look at this uh I'll
chime in myself I B 650 since day one
and I think this is the second term
we've seen this as well I was on the
fence I can see the merits of it on both
sides um but after the last hearing on
this knowing that it's the absolute last
thing that the Department of Motor
Vehicle does I look at it a little bit
different I'm also a little concerned
that it seems every time we try to
reduce the ways people are responsible
for breaking the laws the worst things
get U bail reform comes to mind uh
because of it's the last resort and
because we need teeth in law some where
to get people to comply with their
decisions or the decisions made I don't
think this is a good idea to pursue at
this time uh so I will be voting to not
recommend that being said um I'll ask
the clerk to call the role and she's
ready again the motion is to not
recommend representative Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill
yep representative foot yes
representative C yes representative sers
yes representative Coker yes
representative
Sykes
no representative St Clair
yes representative
Fox
no representative Romo no representative
a
no representative Horgan no
representative plumon
yes Representative parshall
no and chairman Walsh
yes
116 all right motion of not recommend
future legislation is adopted 116 I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill
650 uh few minutes please next up uh H
bu 1273
that
so for
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill 1273 FN relative to the
protection of personal information and
driver's licenses chair recognizes
representative Gorski for a motion thank
you Mr chairman uh my motion is uh to
recommend future legislation on
1273 uh motions to recommend any do I
have a second representative sers
seconds care to speak to your motion sir
I do thank you um when we heard this
bill one of the things that um struck me
is I I I reflected on the establishments
that I go to and um them asking to take
my license and to scan it and for no
apparent reason valid but I don't know
what they're doing with my information
and I think more and more establishments
are doing that I'm more concerned with
what they're doing with our personal
information and I think this is a bill
worth looking into in the future to
maybe tighten it a little bit um so that
you know there's some privacy issues
that can be taken a look
at thank you sir anybody else from the
committee no seeing I will repres sorry
a little slow on the uptake this morning
um
so I I I'm just I have problems with the
bill as it is written
um uh again though we have uh and so I
can't you know support the motion to
move it forward um I think there are
some real issues that we have that have
to be dealt with but I think it has to
be I think a fresh look would be better
than working on an old piece of
legislation that
has so many in my mind inherent flaw
and so for that reason I can't support
the
motion yeah and our motion doesn't
reflect that we're going to necessarily
take this one and move it forward it's
the concept that I'm looking at I do
agree um that we should be taking a look
and preserving our we're protecting our
information uh I do agree there were a
lot of challenges with the bill that we
had before us but in concept I think we
should uh we should look at it again uh
I know that one section in particular um
just so you know in the work I did with
this I've never I've never had more
lobbyists in this building approach me
than on this bill it was actually
terrifying um and one of the biggest
things was uh the fines for example that
are proposed to be um issued if people
don't destroy the information so yes I I
agree that the particular bill has its
problems but I also think it's something
we should look at and that's why I'm
going to recommend future a piece of
future legislation
uh represent of
London thank you Mr chair I I uh just
have to concur I I have a lot of uh
concerns with the way this legislation
is written I personally think we need
new legislation drafted specifically to
the usage of data after it's it's its
input we heard testimony regarding uh
weal from State one one of our
colleagues State Rep how there was an
insurance agent how it affects chiral
uh airplane tickets hotels all types of
insurance uh the need for titles and
lending um as you stated Mr chair there
was a lot of testimony uh we had it from
the uh New England connectivity and
telecomunications business the New
Hampshire business and industry New
Hampshire Grocers and many others that
were opposed to this I think a fresh
start is what we need to go at so at
this time although I understand the
intent I think we need something new and
fresh coming in specific to what we're
looking for thank you Mr
chair fair enough anybody else from the
committee and again I'm just voting for
the concept I would suspect any new
piece of legislation legislation will
start with a blank sheet of RSA
2614 uh and away we go so uh with nobody
else from the committee I'll ask the
clerk to call her all and she's ready
the motion on the floor is to recommend
future
legislation representative Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Coker yes representative Sykes
no did you hear
me representative St Clair
yes representative
Fox
no representative Rambo no
representative veu
yes representative
Horgan
no Representative plumon
no representative
parshall chairman Walsh
yes
116 our recommendation of recommend
future legislation is adopted 116 I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill
1273 uh next
up for a moment this is Senate Bill
465 e
right now opening up the executive
session of Senate Bill
465 relative to motorist duties When
approaching Highway emergencies
involving a stopped or standing
vehicle is there a motion to recommend
or not recommend
I
wow well we need a motion
represent rmo thank you I'll make a
motion to recommend
please motion is to recommend do I have
a
second
I'll representative fo seconds care to
speak to your motion yeah just briefly
um I I really I recall there being just
some philosophical differences on on the
need for this bill or not I in my
opinion and based on some of the
testimony we heard um it it just
actually makes it cleaner the state
police testify that you know a move over
l
any vehicles on the side of the road uh
not distinguishing between emergency
vehicle versus disabled vehicle um I
think it makes it easier and clearer for
drivers um and and would put into statue
what it's best
practice anybody else from the committee
thank you by the
way representative Koger thank you Mr
chairman I just uh the same opinion I
had on this you can't legislate Common
Sense than you
anybody else represents
sees so um it's my opinion that um
sometimes people can accept a little
guidance about how things might be
better done and um the list of uh
agencies and um private and public that
are in support of this bill was pretty
overwhelming and I I think that they've
studied this issue to realize that uh
that it will make a difference and it'll
help protect people on the highways more
so than
not representative Hill thank you um
just
yesterday uh there was a there was a a
car on the side of the road and someone
decided that they needed to move over um
without looking whether I was there or
not um so I this some of this scares the
Dickens out of me when it uh when it
says move over and I understand when it
is uh um flashing yellow green or or red
lights but this was pushing uh for
anyone off to the side of the road and
that um made it difficult for me I mean
you oftentimes you don't know if you're
driving if you're in the passing Lane
you cannot see that car and not be able
to to anticipate that person in the in
the traveling Lane coming over um for
whatever reason and that was the part
that worried me um so I'm not sure
I again whether this is recommended or
not recommended I don't think it's going
to stop anybody from putting in a bill
or not putting in a bill so I'm
perfectly happy to go either way on this
but it uh it for me um it's a hard thing
to make it a um a mandatory thing across
the board
thanks anybody
else George thinks he's getting the last
work
represent I I might be I don't know um
so I I think some one of the testimonies
that I was uh most mindful of was from
the triaa um and they they were pretty
elaborate about their support for this
um I would also make note that while we
can we shouldn't make legislation based
on
anecdotal uh points but rather we should
be looking at the data and then the
final point that I would make that
hasn't been brought up today but I would
mention and and maybe wasn't brought up
in committee um was that um more and
more cars of a newer age are putting
Lane protection and they're warning
people about the size now is it perfect
no no system is perfect but I think when
you balance improving Tech remember we
when we when we're looking at safety
we're trying to get to education
technology and um
enforcement and I think that those on
those fronts we are making enough
progress to justify the uh
recommendation that this bill be carried
forward representative Rumble at risk of
trying to sound like I'm trying to have
the last word here I just I did want to
mention terms of recommending or not
there is language in there about if
practical I recognizing that people are
not necessar going to be able to get
over in all instances this that's all
I'll argue about for
now representative St
Clair thanks and uh if practical is a
pretty big hole because now you become
you become the Observer of the person to
see if what they did was practical or
not and
paraphrase representative Hill I'm not
I'm terrified now when I see cars pulled
over to they may be relieving themselves
switching drivers taking a break because
now if this goes into effect I got to
watch out for a kneejerk reaction from
somebody that all of a sudden oh my God
and then because there were no warning
lights to give them notice as they
approach um it it's it's a real throw of
the dice um I just want people to think
about that thank you anybody
else represent sellers thank you Mr
chair my only thought is that you know
trying to keep a standard throughout the
United States I know we're only New
Hampshire but Most states have uh the uh
red blue and yellow lights and if you
start doing everybody especially we're a
vacation state from people coming from
how to state they're going to be very
confused if they're supposed to or not
all right representative
Smith um so the the language in this a
disabled vehicle meaning a vehicle that
is in a traffic lane or on the side of a
traffic lane that a reasonable person
would conclude is
disabled how am I supposed to know if
it's disabled or they pulled over to
answer their phone do do I have to try
to look through the back window to
decide if I should move over or not I
mean the idea might be okay but if I can
get a ticket for this I don't think the
language
Works anybody
else I have to agree with a lot of the
points that were mentioned this in my
opinion while I agree with the Move Over
Law is just another piece of legislation
trying to legislate common sense um when
you double that with the enforceability
of it I don't see how or why this is
necessary I would prefer to see a topic
like this reinforced in driver education
for
example with nothing else
said I'll ask the clerk to call the rule
whenever she's ready the motion is to
not
recommend ah oh it's to recommend oh oh
okay it's re the motion is to
recommend
so well Al let the cler to call the
rooll
rep Gorski
no rep Smith
no clerk Vats no rep Hill no rep foot no
rep c no rep sellers no no rep Coker no
rep
Sykes yes rep St Clair
no rep
Fox yes rep rbo yes rep be
yes rep
Horgan
yes R plumon
yes R parshall
yes chairman Walsh
no
710 okay so the motion to recommend
fails 7 to 10 uh do we have a new motion
because we can't leave business at that
so representative sellers yeah thank you
Mr chair I'll motion to not recommend
okay motion is to not recommend seconded
by representative CER I don't believe we
have any further discussion so seeing no
hands I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll when she's
ready again the motion is to not
recommend
rep Gorski yes rep Smith yes clerk votes
yes rep Hill
yes rep foot yes rep c yes rep sellers
yes rep Coker yes rep Sykes no rep St
Clair
yes rep
Fox no rep rbo
no rep v
no rep Horgan
no rep plumon no
r parshall
no chairman Walsh
yes
107 okay the motion to not recommend is
adopted 107 I'll close the executive
session
on Senate Bill
465 and our last one for this bium in a
couple of moments Senate Bill
e
e e
okay I'll open up the executive session
on Senate Bill 581 relative to temporary
driver's licenses and non-driver
identification
cards uh do I have a
motion representative SES
are you disappointed I don't have one in
the
gate um my motion would be to recommend
uh future
legislation motion is to recommend
future legislation is there a second
second second by representative V you
care to speak to your motion
sir so
um I think that this this was this was a
good faith B part effort in the Senate
to um fix a a unnown
problem um
both Republican and Democratic senators
voted in favor of this bill it uh as I
recall the Department of Motor Vehicles
also testified in favor of this bill I I
think that it um we should move forward
with the with the with fixing a problem
that our constituents are fac
and for that reason I would urge my
colleagues to recommend future
legislation for
this anybody else from the committee
representative
V thank you Mr chairman um this this
bill just fixes a a kind of a flaw in
the the uh license renewal process we
can renew online but um you can't print
your your receipt showing that you that
you did renew and have that as a valid
um evidence of of renewal right now you
can print it and you can present it to
an officer but there's no legal oppos
obligation for that officer to accept it
so um you you would run the risk of
having to prove that you're that you've
uh renewed your license in other ways or
or be fined for operating the expired
license um I think where we got caught
up as a committee was uh on the the part
that says that it's not valid for voting
and um I think uh if you look at RSA
65913 it allows for an expired license
to be used as uh proof of ID for voting
so um and the the language that's in the
the bill is also already in the law so
um if we need to change that then I
think something we need to recommend
down the road but I would support fixing
that flaw or that that administrative of
detail in the law through through future
legislation represent Gori thank you Mr
chairman
um when I reread this bill and I
remember listening listening to the
testimony about half of it I have no
problem with the one I have a problem
with is literally in the beginning where
there's a line in here that states the
right of a non-resident to drive a
vehicle in this State while holding a
valid driver's
license issued by another
state and to me the way I read this is
that we're going to provide someone a
license that's been given by another
state but we don't know what the other
state has done in terms of vetting that
person so I have a problem with that
particular section and that's kind of
one of the reasons why I cannot
recommend moving this for future
legislation
anybody
else I'll just add this um I'm also not
in favor of this moving forward and I
will be supporting to not recommend and
it's not just because of the problems
with the bill it's the problems with the
whole Theory uh to begin with I think
the problem is deeper than that years
ago you never needed to wait for your
new driver's license you got it before
you walked out of the building so now I
look at this te Technologies increasing
and the security and and the protections
of our information and our new fancy
real IDs and stuff is for our own
benefit but we're just going to give you
a piece of paper for now I mean none of
it makes any sense I think the problem
we have are are much greater no offense
um so why would I want to fix something
I think is broken inherently uh that's
why I'm going to be voting to not
recommend and have the conversation
about uh the rest of what I just
mentioned in the
future with nobody else I'll ask the
clerk to call the role when she's ready
motion is to actually where am I at
motion's to recommend motions to
recommend I will be voting against
that rep Gorski no rep Smith no clerk
votes no rep Hill no rep foot no rep c
no rep sers no rep Coker no rep rep
syes yes rep St Clair yes rep
Fox yes rep rbo yes rep veu yes rep
Horgan
yes RIP plumon yes rep parshall yes
chairman Walsh
no 8
n okay so the motion to recommend fails
8 to9
um we need a motion to complete our
business for the
bium what represent Koger I recommend to
not uh recommend for further legislation
all right motion to not recommend we
have a second for
it represent sellers yeah did you care
to speak to it or have we had enough
discussion on it I like what you said
okay all right any other
discussiones so one of the things that I
see happening uh that is of concern to
me is that
uh technology is changing and the way
that the general public deals with the
government agencies is changing and if
we if we want one of the things I've
heard over and over and over and over
again from my colleagues is that if we
have a law it should represent what the
people are willing to support and here
we are trying to make it A A system that
the
public I believe would support and would
be willing to would be happy to see and
yet we are tossing it away again and I I
just I I hope that um in the upcoming
two-year session will'll be um have
wonderful opportunities to reflect on
changing Technologies and the way our
government deals with our citizens
anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role the motion is to not
recommend future legislation on Senate
Bill
581 rep Gorski yes rep Smith yes clerk
votes yes rep Hill yes rep foot yes rep
c yes rep sellers yes rep Coker yes rep
Sykes emphatically no rep St Clair no
rep Fox no rep Romo no rep veu no rep
Horgan no r plumon no rep parall
no chairman Walsh yes
98 all right so recommendation not to
recommend uh is adopted 19 8 I'll close
the executive session on Senate Bill
581 before we go home I want to thank
everybody
again uh for good I always say good two
years we all don't always agree in
transportation but I don't think we hate
each other that's a good thing uh I
would like to thank again representative
Shen for substituting not just for as a
member but as our clerk who a huge help
um and again thanks everybody anybody
not running that's on Transportation now
do we have any goodbyes to to say or are
we all going to give it another
shot well looks like we're all going to
give it another shot so well everybody
good luck with your
elections it doesn't mean we're going to
be here but uh
what no I that's very true very
true so without anything for the good of
the cause um I guess that'll conclude
our
business all right thanks very
much yeah